welcome class of 2018 it's hard to
believe that three years ago I SAT where
you are sitting recently the prestigious
Princeton Review ranked Hillsdale tenth
and happiest students of all colleges in
the country the reason it's the people
we are all here because we believe in
higher things like Beauty truth and
goodness even if you haven't learned
exactly how to express them yet we want
to know what it means to be able to
think to learn to wonder so we come to
this place because it is full of
professors and students who earnestly
pursue the answers to these questions
when he comes home or she the first time
they're likely to slip and mention that
in certain number of days they're about
to go back home and that will strike at
the heart as we do ask you to make a
commitment during this ceremony and
that's because we need and we welcome
your help word college means partnership
nobody thinks of it that way anymore
welcome to the partnership things are
the way they are here for reasons that
are written in our nature's and we can't
get rid of them the heart of the matter
is to raise yourself to a being that
knows what it is and what it is for and
I want you to know you're very welcome
here and we're so glad to have you
you